five water bottles water bottles
something I've used for many many years
you know always the way with water
bottles on how effective it is think
about what you live right now wherever
you live right now I want you to think
about the last time that you got done
doing something where you said I would
love to have a CO bottle of water and
nothing was around and imagine what
happens how we feel when we take that
first sip of cold water you feel like
you're in heaven right well you can
provide that experience of heaven on
earth to other people where at the end
of a hiking trail so imagine a trail
that's very famous in your area and
thousands of people go on a Sunday or
Saturday well you go out there on the
bottom you buy a bunch of our water
bottles locally buy the smaller ones and
get hundreds of them put them in the
whole ice bucket have them there and
people are coming out have the wrap
around it be local real estate agent
your picture on it with a phone number
local insurance send you your picture on
their phone number whatever it is that
you're gonna be marketing when they come
down Hanuma bottle of water and say
listen i know you're thirsty here it is
you don't have to raise no money we want
nothing from you but my informations are
there if you need any help with real
estate please feel free to call me you
hand out a hundred bottle water bottles
of water how many of them are gonna
really do business with you every one of
them no but if three do business with
you you make 17 grand on commission was
it worth $200 on bottles yes again
another method of guerilla marketing